[Musique]
epsilon alésia zarrad crazy sur i can et
onyx
ce sont les noms de six groupe hard rock
qui viennent de vitry-le-françois
brienne le château où d'autres villes
petites et moyennes de champagne ardenne
depuis cet après midi et jusqu'à 23
heures
il anime l'un des premiers festivals de
hard rock de la région à
châlons-sur-marne le hard rock une
musique très particulière ces amateurs
ont aussi un look très particulier mais
il ne se veulent pas pour autant
marginaux
[Musique]
m
enfin on s'habille comme on le ressent
on a pas de barrière pas de norme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fin de compte on n'est pas des
marginaux il y en a qui bossent quand
même qu'on les possibilités de pouvoir
produire quelque chose faire quelque
chose donc pour moi personnellement on
n'est pas des marginaux
je reste deux langues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis deux ans et accueille de grands
groupes internationaux qui sont passés à
reims ce
curieusement il ya deux ans à changer de
miss italie tête-à-tête amiante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en deux ans ils veulent et quand ils
voyaient lait cru par ce site à la
violence alors c'est tout à fait faux
on dira ce qu'on porte des clous qu'on
va chercher la violence c'est
nous on est contre ça pour que cette
éventualité lors
[Musique]
en fait c'est pas nous qui rejetons les
autres c'est plutôt la société les gens
qui nous rejette canton par exemple
quand on se présente pour un emploi
qu'on s'habille comme ça avec les clous
le canton a les cheveux longs combats on
est sûr de ne pas être pris c'est les
gens dont j'ai tant
[Musique]
cette musique me relu les entrailles et
c'est plus fort que moi faut que je sois
là
c'est ma passion si j'y retourne mais là
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]